alen wake 2 is a sequel that is just as
good as its predecessor alen wake 1 was
an ambitious and impressive title from
remedy entertainment and 13 years later
they've done it again with Alan Wake 2
today we're going to be talking about
the story of Alan Wake 2 to hopefully
piece together what's going on here
while also occasionally stopping to not
only theorize about some of its more
vague story elements but also critique
those said elements along the way all
will be explained in due time though but
before we begin I have a few notes to
bring up thanks to remedy for getting me
an early code so I can have some time to
play the game before release and I also
want to give a warning for both spoilers
and flashing lights elen W 2 has a ton
of flashing lights and while I've done
my best to remove them you should be
careful if you're sensitive to that kind
of thing as for the spoilers we're going
to be talking about alen W 2 in its
entirety so make sure to beat the game
and come back if you need a quick
refresher on the first release I made a
video similar to this one last week on
the first game which covers the base
game the dlc's the spin-off American
Nightmare and a brief talk about the
alen M DLC in control so make sure to
watch that video first if you need to
without further Ado though like the
video if you enjoy and subscribe if
you're new check out my other story
analysis videos on a variety of games
and series if this content interests you
and let's get
started Alan W 2 starts with us taking
control of someone who just swam out of
culton Lake obviously this is the same
Lake that leads into the dark place but
the person who escaped was aent
Nightingale from the first game the game
itself confirms this later but you could
actually spot this beforehand as one of
the first things he says is Hemingway a
reference to his old bit last we saw him
he was taken by the dark presence but
was briefly seen at the end of the first
game being used by the presence likely
as a tool while walking he ends up
stumbling upon a few random people out
in the woods nigh Andale was then taken
and sacrificed by the cult in some kind
of ritual kind of sucks he died this
early as I was hoping to see more of him
but at least he got to make an
appearance at all regardless this
finally Begins the game in Earnest but
instead of playing as Alan Wake we play
as FBI agent Saga Anderson who's
partnered with another agent named Alex
Casey both of these characters are
important in their own way revolving
around their names Saga and as will
eventually learn is related to Tor and
Odin Anderson the Rockstar brothers
whose band is the old gods of Asgard and
Alex Casey shares the same name as the
fictional detective from Alan wake's
Alex Casey book series the first logical
thing to consider is that Alan Wake
created him as a way to get him out of
the dark place but as we know Alan can
create something from nothing what most
likely happened is that he found someone
named Alex Casey and then made him
become a detective so while Alex Casey
the person was always real Alan may have
lined up his life in a way that made him
become an FBI agent what's rather
interesting though is that Alex Casey
has the same voice actor in face as Max
Payne since that's what he was always
designed to be meaning Alex Casey is an
early tease of what max pain will look
like when remedy eventually remakes the
games the reason they're here is because
they were visiting bride Falls to
investigate the missing people who were
killed here years ago but as soon as
they arrive someone else was murdered
which is that scene when n Andale
earlier upon arriving Saga is able to
deduce that the murder of Nightingale
matches up with the mo of the other
victims this easily proves that the cult
is behind the prior killings and that
this is as a part of a ritual while
trying to find the killer the duo finds
a manuscript page which is obviously
written by Allan that describes the duo
reading the page they just read to Saga
and Casey this makes no sense but to us
the players this is very much Alan
wake's work without knowing where to
proceed after reading the page they
decide to handle things normally and
proceed with an autopsy this takes them
to Bright Falls where they meet with
Sheriff breaker however this isn't Sarah
breaker but her cousin Tim breaker Sarah
unfortunately does not make an
appearance in this game as she left the
sheriff position and become a federal
agent instead with Tim taking her place
it's a shame Quantum break isn't a part
of the remedy connected Universe on
account of them not owning their rights
to it anymore but it's still good to see
sha Ashmore getting rolls from them
although on that note it does feel like
remedy's trying to connect these games
that they've made without using the
actual IPS Tim breaker is tied to a
character I'll talk more about later
called Mr door who has a similar name to
Mr hatch on Quantum break and Alex case
he is obviously meant to be the Allen
wake version of Max pain as they have
the same backstory voice actor and face
model I've always wondered if this was
remedy's way of getting all the games in
the same connected Universe while also
getting around the rights of the games
they don't own Mr door especially since
Tim breaker mentions how he sees Mr door
in many different dreams but in
different circumstances so maybe in
another of his dreams it isn't Tim and
Mr door but Jack Joyce and Mr hatch it's
not a perfect explanation and I wouldn't
consider it a fact either just an
observation as remedy likes to throw in
references to their other games all the
time so it's hard to tell if the
reference is just an Easter egg or
something that should be taken more
seriously either way the following scene
shows Tim breaker being thrown into the
dark place after touching an old stack
of manuscript Pages Nightingale getting
up and escaping to Saga and Casey
chasing after him back at the lake it's
around this time where Saga then
discovers what's called an overlap this
is another plane of existence similar to
the dark place but it seems to be
created as a result of the dark place in
our world merging together Both Worlds
need to contribute for the overlap to be
made the reality of our world connected
with the dark stories or history of a
specific location and a work of our
created in the dark place are what's
used to make this happen the story is
what Allan just wrote and the real event
was n Andale getting his chest cut open
during the ritual which created an
overlap allowing Both Worlds to merge in
that location this doesn't seem to exist
in the real world though which is why
certain steps are necessary to gain
access to them like with this overlap
where we have to say a chant and then
push nill's heart through a hole in a
sign inside said overlap is a lush
Forest that has Saga being hunted by
Nightingale while we're here we get to
learn a bit how Nightingale even managed
to get caught up and all this after
Allen entered the dark place back in the
first game the lake itself started to
recede and along with it took people
whose Hearts were surrounded in darkness
night and Gale among them while in the
dark place he attempted to find wake but
was taken by The Cult of the word sort
of like our current cult here but
different they then killed him and
pushed him out of the lake to find the
clicker the item Allan had used to
defeat the dark presence all those years
ago clearly he hasn't succeeded and he
isn't going to as Saga is able to
finally put him down what follows is a
short talk between her and Allen where
the two seem to see each other but can't
quite hear all the words they're saying
this talk though seems to shoot Saga
back to the shore along with of all
people Allan wake who is now finally out
of the dark place for the first time in
13 years honestly I thought Allan
escaping would have been the finale of
this game not the end of the intro but
it does make sense why this was done so
early on once we make it to the actual
finale as an opening Alan Wake 2 like
the first game starts off really well
remedy is rather good at making
impressive openings that hook the player
in and Allen W 2 is no exception that
being said this praise only comes from a
story perspective as gameplay-wise Allen
wake 2 takes a long long time to really
get into mainly doing parts they just
not being anything to actually shoot at
I'll elaborate on the combat a bit later
when we get to it but at the time of
recording I was 3 hours into the game
and had only killed about five enemies
much of this time was spent exploring
the new wide areas the game has added
but still even as someone who focuses on
the stories of games on this channel
gamep playay is important first and
foremost and it will take a long time
for the player just to get a feel for
the mechanics let alone come to a
conclusion on whether or not they
actually enjoy it in the first place
Saga then decides to bring Allen back to
the Bry Falls Lodge to get an idea as to
what's going on as this is all still new
to her according to their talk Allan
doesn't remember writing the pages and
that these pages are from a book called
return return may be familiar to some of
you as that was the same one he wrote an
American nightmare but while the title
is the same the contents are different
he's written many different versions of
return hoping that it will return him to
the real world but none have worked out
and American Nightmare was one of those
failed attempts to get a bit more
context were then given control of Allen
so we could see what happened from his
perspective his journey starts with him
waking up backstage at a late show
called between with Mr D the host of
course is none other than Mr door he
liked many elements of this game were
te's back in remedy's Prior game control
as one of Dylan's dreams talked about a
man named Mr door and how he shifted
between realities and here though we
just seems to be a late show host but
numerous manuscript Pages seem to point
to Mr dor just going along with the
charades that he can achieve his real
goal here in the dark place according to
him though Allan's new book initiation
is set to release tomorrow and it's
going to be a sequel to departure this
confirms a long running Theory which is
that Allan is trying to complete the the
hero's journey this concept is a writing
structure first created by Joseph
Campbell in which he describes how there
must be certain steps made in a story
that the hero must go on there are 17
steps in the process but it can be
boiled down to three distinct acts
departure initiation and return or more
specifically the plot of Alan Wake 1 the
current plot with Allen and then the
plot with Saga saga's story in Alan Wake
2 is influenced by the manuscript pages
that belong to the book return an
initiation is Allen's journey in the
dark place before washing up on that
Shore this is further reinforced by what
is supposed to occur in these acts
departure usually has the protagonist go
from everyday normal life to a bizarre
and twisted one thanks to a specific
event just like Allan went from being a
writer to having to fight the dark
presence initiation is meant to be the
same protagonist learning his way in the
world that he's been thrown into which
is going to mirror Allen's upcoming
campaign and return as the protagonist
return to his old world or life with
their reward sometimes that person will
use their skills or weapons to defeat
the evil that caused them to leave in
the first place or they might sacrifice
themselves to save the ones that they
love this is meant to be saga's Campaign
which is not as obvious now but we'll
start to make more sense as we continue
there are also many steps within these
acts which surprisingly still match up
like how within the departure act the
hero must meet with a mentor which is
when Allan meets with Thomas Zayn as
well as cross the first threshold which
is when Allan sacrificed himself at the
end of the first game but those are the
three basic acts this is also why Allan
failed an American Nightmare as he
skipped the step while trying to escape
he tried to return without going through
his initiation now that doesn't mean
American Nightmare isn't Cannon as it
most definitely is it's just one of
Allen's many attempts to escape the dark
place using return before realizing that
he needed the initiation part to make it
work after the talk show was over alen
is left to explore the rest of the
building and located in the back is ATI
the janitor from control ati's role in
control has always been a mystery and
Alan way 2 isn't going to help us get
any answers either but I believe AI to
be for a lack of a better word a
supernatural helper not only does ATI
like a real janitor have keys to all the
worlds as he's been freely traveling
between the real world the oldest house
and now the dark place but he always
seems to show up when the protagonist
needs him when Jesse couldn't get past
the ashtray maze ATI was there to help
and he's also going to be helping Allan
quite a few times by pointing him in the
right direction such as now he's like a
physical DSX Machina in a lot of ways
this time around ATI wants Allen to go
downstairs and get the lamp from The
Shoe Box this lamp is the same one that
belonged to the clicker the clicker was
the switch that would turn on this lamp
as such it has similar magical powers as
Allen is able to capture light into the
lamp and then release it into other
places which adds more complexity to the
puzzles
upon going outside he is greeted by a
call from Thomas Zayn who'll be seeing
much more of shortly for now he tells
Allan how to find a murder site as these
sites are going to help him Escape like
many things within this game though this
part about the killings is quite
confusing and not one I'm fully
confident I understand all of this in by
extension the rest of Allen's campaign
take place in the dark place but these
ritualistic killings we find are real
and not real at the same time the person
we meet when walking down the streets of
this fictional New York is Alex Casey
but not the same one from earlier Casey
will die in just a few moments via the
dark presence yet not only does he show
up later but he's still alive in the
present day these killings we're trying
to find have also seemed to have
happened as the FBC has a note about the
cult called The Cult of the word who are
the ones doing the killings furthermore
despite Casey dying we find Echoes of
him throughout the dark place one of
which mentions the cul by name and the
killing we're about to find even though
this is after implying that Casey
actually lived these events it's to my
understanding that the cult of the word
and Casey being the lead investigator on
this case actually happened as I can't
imagine the FBC report is lying the only
issue is how much of this is real in
regards to the story this report was
found during saga's campaign so how much
of the book return is influencing this
furthermore this could all be the work
of Mr scratch as long story short
scratch is not only the author of return
or saga's campaign but he's obviously
still alive in Allen's both Cults the
word in Allen and the tree in sagas are
different from each other but they are
very similar as they both refer to
themselves as Cults which not even real
Cults do but if scratch is the leader
behind The Cult of the word it's clear
that this was the inspiration behind the
cult of the tree when he was writing
return regardless this cult I stated
before goes by The Cult of the word and
the reason they're tied to Alan Wake is
because they're reenacting deaths from
Alex Casey's book series by killing
people in the same way to them Alan Wake
is their Messiah and the books are their
Bible this specific killing happened at
a subway station a bunch of these
cultists seem to have killed a bunch of
people by trapping them in a subway car
and then set it on fire walking through
this is horrifying as their charred and
lifeless bodies are accompanied by
constant screams of pain it gives me
some flashbacks to spec Ops the Line and
that's definitely not a game that spawns
some pleasant thoughts eventually Allen
is able to change the scene to reflect
the ritual allowing him passage into the
previously blocked tunnel inside the
tunnel was the murder sight Allan was
looking for witches of Nightingales
these murder sites are Rena sance
overlaps as following each one as a
conversation between Allen and Saga just
like we saw from saga's perspective
earlier these overlaps on Allen's side
at least allow the parliament Tower to
appear which is where he and Alice used
to stay back in New York once Alan makes
it to their apartment he sees that Alice
still has the cameras on which she put
up to photograph the monster who keeps
appearing in her home every night she
seems to have taken these pictures and
used them to make an exhibit showing the
world the horrors of her life it's also
the first time we the player have seen
Alice in a very long time going through
the screens takes Alan back to the
writer's room only to find a dead body
of himself in the chair which ends the
episode and finally puts an end to this
damn prologue apologies if that summary
was a bit longer than expected I
probably could have ended this prologue
section and started rambling a lot
earlier but it felt better to stop at
here due to what happens after as now
the player is able to play Saga and
Allen's story at any time in any order
they wish that brief time with Allen did
not end with him on the shore which
means there's more to the story in a
narrative order thanks to the title of
the book initiation is the one that
happens first the player can do all of
Allen's story first then sagas do one
chapter at a time or any other
combination this is a pain in the ass
for the purposes of nailing down the
story but it's exceptional game design
as the players given the freedom to play
how they want
if Saga section or gameplay is just not
driving with you at the moment then you
can switch back to Allen and vice versa
if the current story arc feels boring or
sluggish then you could just take a
break and switch to another character
and you could do this in the middle of
the missions too as long as the safe
room has a black puddle inside it that's
why this prologue section is so long
because we now just got the chance to
switch campaigns at will Sam Lake
director of Remedy entertainment
mentioned how one of his goals was to
make longer games as it's hard to make
them longer using the kind of ideas he
has well I can confidently say that
worked as that whole Pro L took about 6
and 1/2 hours to get through which as a
comparison alen wake 1 without DLC took
10 hours to complete in any case this
what I'll call a prologue is great as it
teaches the player the mechanics of each
character and how they'll go about the
world in their campaigns we'll also
setting up the story and its dangling
Mysteries and thanks to the game giving
the player the choice of how they want
to continue the player is able to play
the content that they're most interested
in first if seeing Allen's story was
more intriguing to them then they could
start with that but if Saga was more
intriguing to the player early on and
they could start with her side of the
story first it's probably the best
handled dual protagonist system that
I've ever seen The Last of Us Part Two
also had two protagonist in the form of
Ellie and Abby but many players were
annoyed by the amount of content they
had to do as Abby not just because of
what she meant to the story but because
her entire campaign came right after
Ellie's so the player had to go through
the same three days in Seattle but is
someone else the story also left off on
a cliffhanger one that wouldn't be seen
until after the player goes through
aby's side of the story which was at
least 12 hours long part of me wers how
this game would have been received had
Naughty Dog opted to take remedy's
approach to it instead now to be fair to
Naughty Dog The Last of Us and Allan
Wake deal with very different subject
matter and stories so it's possible that
it would have never worked to begin with
but Alan W 2 really opened my eyes to
this style of Storytelling as giving the
player the option to switch off at any
time might have lessened the boredom
that many players experience while
playing The Last of Us Part Two remedy
has always been one to change things by
going bigger better and usually weirder
and I think the way they created this
dual protagonist system is a test into
their creativity as I've never seen
something like this handled before this
well as I said before though Allen's
story happens first due to initiation me
in the second book in the story so while
my initial playthrough was filled with
constant back and forth switching I'm
going to organize it one campaign at a
time to make things easier to digest
this means we're going to be talking
about Allen's first but I want to
briefly talk about the game play just in
case you're someone who hasn't played
the game yet fortunately most of the
game is just like the last such as using
light to defeat the Shadows then
peppering them with bullets the
difference is that the movement in
combat in general feels very similar to
the more recent Resident Evil remakes I
wanted to point that out specifically
because quite a few of you in the
previous video mentioned how the
gameplay was stopping you from enjoying
the story so if you're one of those
people you might want to consider
playing the second game to see how it
feels I think my only gripe is that the
flashlight isn't a continuous hold
anymore but more of an action meaning
one press removes a set amount of
flashlight battery and while that's fine
if you aren't perfect with its placement
you'll only be able to remove some of
the Shadow forcing you to use another
part of the battery for such a small
amount of shadow as an isolated incident
it wouldn't be too much of a problem but
Allen WG 2 makes everything finite
meaning health and batteries don't
recharge anymore so you have to play
frugally and carefully outside of that
though the gameplay does what it needs
to while I prefer the previous game's
flashlight mechanics I can understand
that it was most likely added to elevate
the survival horror experience with that
done though let's get back to the story
where we last left off Allan just found
his own body in the writer zo before
being overtaken by some kind of presence
the next chapter picks up back in the
writer's room again the dark presence
was able to stop Allen and now he has to
escape again alen wake is once again
stuck in a Time Loop however it's
different a message of this game hammers
home quite a bit is that it's not a loop
but a spiral a loop implies that the
same events are happening every single
time without change but a spiral is a
slight change over time that will
eventually lead to a new end American
Nightmare was a loop Alan W 2 is a
spiral he might be going through the
same locations and doing the same things
but how and where he finds these murder
sites and what he experiences changes
each time bringing him closer and closer
to an escape helping them keep track of
this is his writer's room Saga has her
own room called The Mind place but it's
structured a bit differently due to
their lines of work storywise Allen's
board is used as a way to collect the
thoughts of his everchanging mind as he
seems to lose his memories quite
frequently as well as plan out the steps
of the current draft he's working on for
the story Alan can also use the board to
change the scenes he's in along him
entry to other parts of the dark place
that tunnel that was previously blocked
in the prologue was unlocked by taking
the setting and changing the scene Allan
needs to write his way out so things he
can come across can be used as
inspiration to write the story it's a
nice mechanic that is both a gameplay
and story device that makes the two
blend more seamlessly together as a
concept I really like the spiral idea as
well as the writer's room and I'm really
glad American Nightmare was used as the
jumping off point for it as it
introduced both the idea of Loops into
Allen wake as well as the scene setting
idea like I said in that previous video
a bad game doesn't mean it had bad ideas
it takes a lot of intelligence to admit
that something you had might have been
great but was just in the wrong place an
American Nightmare was full of great
Concepts just waiting to be used in
something with more time and budget and
I'm really glad that remedy was able to
finally make that happen with Alan Wake
2 speaking of which remedy also seems to
have taken a few pages from control as
these hard tose memory things are
reminiscent of the brief scenes we see
in control that are a part of the
hotline and it also carries over the
fulls screen title card for each chapter
it really seems like control was where
remedy found its style which makes sense
given it was the first game in years
that they were able to make without
outside interference as Quantum break
and even Allen W one to an extent are
published by Microsoft but control was
the their first independent game in a
long time and it's been fascinating to
see in real time how the dev team has
grown and found their style sometimes
though that style makes them get a
little bit carried away such as what
occurs in the following scene as Alan
Wake is once again backstage but instead
of sitting down and answering questions
the whole crew performs a musical I feel
like remedy sat down and said you
remember the as tray maze on control we
should keep that same tone but add
elements of the Dynamite song with Dr
darling cuz that's exactly what this is
It's a Long fight with with our own
background music once again performed by
the old gods of Asgard they also never
seem to let things go to waste if they
add something to the game it's going to
have time in the script as this is a
whole 14 minute long section what's
annoying is that I hate that they were
right about this though because I love
the astray Maze and I love this scene
here too for equally the same reasons
and I thought this place couldn't get
any stranger yeah you and me both just
like last time exiting the building has
Allen getting a call from Thomas Zayn
Allan seems to remember the call from
last time which surprised Tom as this is
a first further proving that Allen is
moving in a spiral not a loop the rest
of the chapter is going to be the same
though as we have yet another murder
site to find the murder this time around
involves a play at the hotel was a play
about a murder cult played by an actual
murder cult which is very meta the
reason this play was performed here at
this hotel was because it was said to be
haunted as a real cult performed
sacrifices here in the building where
things start to get concerning is that
the devil is supposed to be a part of
the play but the person who played the
devil was some BigTime celebrity who was
always in character even before the play
started the cast was actually concerned
that they had hired the devil to play
himself where the murder comes in is
that the person playing the devil knew
the woman who was playing The Muse in
the play and used the play as a way to
murder her Cold Case Casey is now once
again on the case and believes that this
devil character is Mr scratch linging
into his connection with the cult to get
there Allen is going to have to take a
trip to this fictional New York he's
crafted up and I got to say this game is
gorgeous the brightly lit signs crowding
the sky and the piled up cars really
make this place feel abandoned the taken
that Lit the street also adds to the
horror elements as something unique to
Allen's campaign is that the taken don't
always want to kill him I still haven't
quite figured out how the mechanic Works
myself but some of the taken just
disappear if you get too close as an
element of the game design it means that
getting too close might get you killed
but passively shooting at anything in
your way means you'll be wasting ammo on
enemies that weren't trying to kill you
it's a really unique take on the
survival horror genre and their constant
comments about Allen really make the
hairs on your neck stand up alen will
then eventually arrive at the hotel to
see what's going on and hopefully gain
some inspiration which I find to be
hilarious as alen hears these horrific
Tales like yeah an entire train of
people just burned to death or a cult
murdered a whole hotel and Allan goes
wow this is going to be amazing material
for the script as if that's not like the
most terrific thing to ever grace his
ears now it is explained that the story
needs to get more and more gruesome so
it can amplify the writing and hopefully
make it easier to escape but it's always
odd to remember that Allen's writings
can rewrite reality meaning the fates of
everyone from the first game were
because of him it really puts in
perspective the amount of power he has
and how dangerous this device can be as
one wrong step and it's over stopping
some of that inspiration is a film reel
that sends him into the room with the
Thomas Zayn this is the first time we've
seen Thomas's face before and while
could be another trick like in control a
newspaper of him and Barbara confirms
that this is the real Thomas Zayn this
explains why ATI and the Anderson
Brothers keep calling him Tom as they
look the same however it's never
explained why similar to control the
conversation just doesn't feel quite
right not not only does Zayn not bring
up his poetry and insisting that he's a
filmmaker but he also talks about Allan
and him collaborating on a project that
he doesn't remember Zay claims Allan was
going to write return while he crafted a
film that together would be enough to
get them both out of the dark place but
Allan doesn't remember writing return
just like last time Allan is going to
have to find certain scenes and use
those to change the story I know we
already talked about this before but I
seriously cannot get over how
technically impressive this whole thing
is changing the scene is seamless and
takes less than a couple seconds and yet
not only did I run into any hitches when
changing scenes but remedy took the time
to actually design each location around
the theme the scene doesn't change the
whole area only a few specific sections
but they still took the time to design
each one around The Inspirations more
often than not the scenes and settings
you find are progressive so scenes you
use in the beginning won't be used in
the final piece as you usually use one
scene GA another only to use that one to
find the next and yet even though most
players may not see all the different
looks across the areas they still made
them anyway and it's the most impressive
part of the game the environmental
storytelling remedy uses throughout
these scene changes is also topnotch as
well but that was never something I was
worried about seeing how they handled
the oldest house and all of its complex
and varied shapes and sizes I knew
remedy was going to nail their new
setting without any effort and they
didn't disappoint both campaigns have
such gorgeous locations that are
distinct enough to immediately tell
where you are just in case you're lost
and they also brought back their old
idea from control where they littered
the area with directional signs allowing
navigation to be easier and not require
the use of the map after you play enough
games from a specific developer certain
things tend to be customary or expected
and when it comes to remedy I never need
to worry about the actual settings
themselves as they've never let me down
once after exploring long enough Alan
will eventually make it to room 108
where the body was dumped after the
devil had killed her this once again
leads to another talk with Saga and the
appearance of the parliament Tower this
time alen is able to find more
recordings of Ellice who talks about the
exhibit like before alen then finds
himself in the writer room except it's
empty he also finds the manuscript Pages
for return which Allan claims was
written by scratch as this wasn't wasn't
something he would ever write he then
starts adding pages to it in attempt to
edit the script waiting for Scratch to
come in and shoot him so now he's gone
from arriving too late to the murder
scene to being the murder victim another
failure but another attempt slowly but
surely creating that spiral third times
the charm as they say so let's do it
again we go through another late night
show interview but this time Mr door
drops the act and tells him he's only
going along with the charade to indulge
him he only exists because someone Mr
dor cares about was thrown into the
story because of Allen and he wants to
get them out which is is shockingly
honest and also really terrifying it's
also not the only time someone calls him
out for this is Saga is going through
the same thing and we berate Allen for
the same reason a bit later
unfortunately we don't get to hear too
much about Mr door after this
conversation so we never find out who
this person is and why they're uniquely
tied to Tim breaker ATI also returns to
tell us about the basement and how
there's photos that we need to collect
these photos are of a clicker and a
bullet these aren't going to be helpful
now but they will soon as they are what
we need to complete the ending to this
story just like last time we meet with
Thomas but the conversation is less
pleasing Thomas confessed to working
with scratch to find a way out because
Allan had given up a long time ago
saying that it wasn't worth it anymore
and that he doesn't deserve to get out
but scratch was determined to leave so
him and Thomas work together instead he
then apologizes before attempting to
what I assume is him taking over control
of the scene again but alen is able to
fight back and shoot him Thomas isn't
dead though as he appears again after
the film has been played out as a sort
of after credit cut scene shown that
this was all an act as for our final
murder site this one is at the cinema
the same one thas Zay was playing his
new film act called nightless night
there's an urban legend around the film
claiming that it's a snuff film and that
there was an actual murder during the
production what's even weirder is that
the film as well as the echo start to
get a bit meta the film itself not only
Stars Alex Casey but after confronting
the grandm he thanks Casey for playing
the role of the fictional detective to
get the writer here before greeting Alan
Wake it should be mentioned that these
Echoes are real things that have
happened Allan originally thought that
these were ideas likely from his past
drafts as he's is losing his memories
constantly but there is one later in the
game with Saga and after the two talk it
becomes clear that these things are real
events how something for the past is
able to be sent forward in time to the
present is not understood but it's not
the only time this has happened later in
saga's campaign she's going to need to
perform a concert to get alen out of the
dark place but while she succeeds in
doing so Allen isn't sent into the
present day but back in time when we
first met him on the shore as another
example Saga needed to find nill's heart
in order to activate this overlap but
when arriving at the crime scene she
discovered that was moved to a nearby
freezer from Allen's side though he was
able to find the heart at the murder
site but it disappeared before he could
touch it almost as if he moved it back
in time for Saga to find it gives off
the impression that there is a set
timeline to things but that future
events could influence the past so that
those future events can happen this same
idea could be applied to The Echoes as
The Grandmaster is talking to Casey and
Alan Wake even though Alan is viewing
this later in time all this culminates
and Allan finally making it to the
murder site the mask in this scene was
the key and just like the heart alen
gets near it only for it to disappear
this mask is used for the parade float
later further confirming that Allan is
helping Saga by sending her specific
items for the final time though we get
another overlap conversation before the
appearance of the parliament Tower
before you leave though you could watch
a clip of that Film thas Z was making
and it's a full-on 15-minute short film
the film itself is rather fascinating
given what transpires the plot seems to
be about Alex Casey falling in love with
a woman called Barbara Jagger she then
drugs him only for the cult of the word
to appear and kill him his death seems
to have released Tom his Zain from the
well allowing him to be free and
reunited with his wife it's important to
remember that this film was supposed to
be used in tandem with return so Tomas
could escape a quote that's repeated in
here is the ritual to lead you on he
returns and you in turn are locked in
the room within the film this means that
Thomas name returns and Alex Casey is
caught in a loop but it feels more
important than that unlike Casey who
plays himself Thomas actually plays
Allan Wake I can't help would feel that
this film was an attempt at sabotaging
either Allen or both Casey and Allen
early on in Allen's campaign pain Casey
is killed by the dark presence when
Allan finds his stuff he says that the
writer has assumed the role of the
detective well this is a bit tongue and
cheek on the surface it could also refer
to Allan taking Casey's place he has
presumably done everything Casey did
when investigating the cult so this film
is likely talking about Allen being left
behind to further reinforce this not
only is the writer's room in the film
but the final line is it's not a loop
it's a spiral which is what Alan will
say at the end of the game ignoring the
fact that remedy literally made an
entire short film and placed it right in
the middle of the game for the player to
enjoy the story itself is rather
interesting as there's so many layers to
it to where a surface level examination
would be missing out on all the small
details following the premiere of the
weirdest film I've ever seen Allan
receives a call from himself telling him
to put the photos Alice took in a shoe
box this Allan he is talking to us from
the future or more specifically a
different place in the timeline just
like our talk about Saga finding Allen
on the shore it's once again a future
Allen talking a past Allen to make sure
the events go in the way they ought to
once again confirming that all of this
is a single timeline that goes back and
forth depending on certain actions
placing these items though takes us back
to Saga as we aren't allowed to continue
without progressing her story while the
middle portion of the story is up to the
player the beginning and the finale of
the story needs to play in the order
remedy wants it to so we need to make it
to the end of saga's story so that we
can catch up on what's going on before
we transfer over to her though let's
talk about Allan for a game named after
him I'm surprised they went with two
protagonists and whether intentional or
not I actually like saga's campaign more
Allen is most definitely a much better
character on account of him already
being in the prior games but I really
enjoyed saga's campaign more Allen story
might be one of the most confusing
things I've ever played and even after
mulling over all the details I still
feel like I don't have a grasp on this
at all there are so many unanswered
questions that I'd hop this game would
answer except it answered none and only
added more but at this point it's become
a remedy staple While most of these plot
threads are left dangling there is
enough to theorize on what could happen
and The Meta elements do make this
campaign a genuinely enjoyable
experience thematically the constant
headaches that would come from trying to
piece together any of this story are in
line with what Allen is trying to do
when writing this book initiation can be
best described as an organized jumbled
mess it's messy out of order and very
confusing but it's all there the
breadcrumb trail is always present and
will lead you somewhere it might not be
the route you wanted and the crumbs
might go in a different direction get
you turned around and go back but it is
going somewhere and I feel like that's
an allegory for a lot of remedy's recent
works it's going to take a lot of time
to get there and you will without
question get lost along the way but you
are going somewhere it's it's fitting
that the middle book in the trilogy is
the most confusing of the three as it's
the middle part of remedy's games the
story starts to feel like an Ever
shifting maze alen wck 1 was confusing
yes but made sense as things started to
unfold and saga's campaign is a lot less
puzzling but Allen's is that awkward
middle from the original Allen way to
control remedy's recent games start with
a stellar and intriguing opening to a
confusing and complicated middle that
then ends with a cliffhanger ending that
ties things up but still leaves them
open for a sequel and I feel like remedy
took that but expanded it over the
course of the three campaigns than this
series alen's campaign is stressful and
utterly confusing to piece together but
I feel like that's the fun of it the
first line of alen wake 1 is a quote
from Stephen King talking about the
beauty of horror is the Unexplained and
that there is little horror to be had in
explanations that the main antagonist
explained its entire motivation then the
mystery is gone in that same vein the
dark presence being this formless entity
with unclear goals outside of wanting to
take over the world is what adds the
Mystique Community discussion is one of
my favorite parts of playing games and
is why make some of these videos in the
first place to act as a sort of hub for
people to pull their ideas into some
games are never going to be solved alone
but enough Community discussion in
theory will eventually lead to an answer
and it's something alen Wick does in
Spades initiation while confusing mess
is a nice mess one that I thoroughly
enjoyed unfortunately I also like
getting answers to my questions which
Allan's campaign rarely does but
thankfully saga's campaign is no
stranger
to saga's campaign might not give us
answers to things in initiation but at
least is not going to leave you
scratching your head every 15 minutes
wondering what the hell is going on when
we last left off Saga kabro Falls to
investigate a series of ritualistic
murders during that time she discovered
Supernatural forces were play and that
Alan Wake a writer that she had heard
had gone missing 13 years ago had just
washed up on the shore next to her Saga
and her partner Alex Casey then decided
to take him back to the lodge the
dynamic between Casey and Saga is a
pleasant one and also inspired by the
crime series True Detective True
Detective is a crime Anthology meaning
that each season has a new set of
characters and stories but many people
including remedy teams really enjoy the
first season the plot is about two
detectives Rus and Cole played by
Matthew MCC and Martin Hart played by
Woody harelson who came to Louisiana to
investigate a murder that turns into a
deeper investigation into a cult the two
characters also seem to be Loosely
connected to our buddy cop Duo as well
Rustin Cole had a daughter named Sophia
who was tragically killed in a car
accident and while saga's daughter Logan
is still alive and well she finds out
very quickly that return is changing the
story of her family which includes her
and her husband divorcing and Logan
drowning to death and Martin is more or
less connected to Alex Casey by way of
the two constantly talking about their
Ex-Wives using something this deliberate
isn't really anything new for remedy as
Stephen King was practically the face of
the first game so it's no wonder they're
continuing that Trend here that said the
duo work quite well together and was a
highlight of saga's campaign hearing the
two bounce ideas off each other while
also seeing how well their personalities
went together made their conversations
they joy to listen to what also added to
the joy of the campaign was saga's
version of the writer room the Mind
place like Allen's way for her to keep
track of all the info she learns to in
the case and I never felt more like a
detective than when I was in this room
the whole thing is separated into Case
Files that have layers upon layers of
info to com over all connected through
posted notes and strings it's also
carefully organized and comes with small
blurs from Saga so you know exactly
what's going on Allan had something like
this to in his room in the form of small
notes on his board but given what
actually happens during that story a lot
of it isn't too helpful the first part
of the case board is about Allen in the
cult and after a brief discussion with
Allen Saga is able to then use him as a
profile along with the case board the
profiling table is used to gather more
information what's bizarre about its
implementation is that Saga is able to
sense things that are never brought up
despite never mentioning this in their
original conversation saga's able to
know that Allan is hiding manuscript
pages on him originally I was baffled as
to how this was even possible and
thought this was just a gameplay gimmick
to progress the story but there is a
real reason why she can do this even if
the explanation is just as bizarre as
the concept itself Saga due to her being
an Anderson has powers so to speak that
allow her to see through the lies and
discover the real truth meaning
everything that occurs in these profiles
actually happened and is our one source
of true information where this talk
takes her is the near my town of watery
as Saga trying to find the clicker that
Allen lost the town itself is filled
with many Lively people all going about
their day and enjoying their life I've
read that taking aana is good for
preventing dementia yeah and so is beer
however many of the people here start to
talk to Saga as if they know her as we
talked about before in Allen section the
book return that scratch wrote is
changing the story and the line between
fact and fiction is becoming very blurry
according According to some of the
residents Saga used to live here with
her daughter and when she mentions how
that's not possible and that her
daughter is back home they try to
console her saying things like hey it's
it's all right I understand that was a
very hard time for you return wrote that
Saga and her husband divorced causing
Saga to take their child Logan to watery
where they lived in a trailer park but
one day Logan drowned in the lake when
Saga wasn't looking it's very
conflicting for her because nothing is
making sense and because she's an
Anderson it can see through the story
she starts questioning whether or not
she's gone crazy as everyone is in
agreeance about what happened except for
her it's a welcome change to the story
so far as we've played as Alan Wake the
Mastermind behind the stories but now
we're playing as one of those people
affected by the story it's like playing
the first game is Nightingale an FBI
agent trying to arrest someone who's
then taken by a shadowy presence a lot
of that was out of his control thanks to
alen pulling the strings and that kind
of makes him come off as an [__] he
does feel bad about what he's done and
we'll mention it repeatedly to Saga but
it's also really terrifying to think of
all the people that he's affected just
to get out in a way though it does make
sense and remedy really nailed this
aspect of Allen as the longer he stays
in the dark place the more numb he
becomes Allen's desperate and doesn't
really care what happens as long as he
gets out and I really enjoy this change
for his character he's still the same
person that we know and love but now
that we're seeing things from Another
Side it starts to put things at a
perspective saga's current objective is
to find the trailer park but to get
there she needs a key but the key is
locked behind a door at the amusement
park coffee World a lot of this game's
objectives are like this where it's a
roadblock blocked by a roadblock but to
get past that roadblock we need to get
past the prior one surprisingly though I
actually didn't mind it as once again if
the story is boring you can just switch
to Allen for a quick change of pace but
I never did that myself as the
exploration in combat helped to carry
the rest of the way alen wake 2 being
more of a horror game also made walking
around areas intense as the creek of a
branch or a loud noise would immediately
gather my attention like I said there
was never a time I felt bored while
playing and while some of the objectives
might have taken a while to get through
I never found myself fatigued by the
content so massive props to remedy for
knowing the pacing of this middle
section at the trailer park is the
Anderson Brothers who are getting drunk
off their moonshine again they also
greet Saga as it's been a while since
they've seen her at the time Saga finds
them to be just as confused as everyone
else but she does learn later that she
is in fact related to the brothers on
that note I love the intentional naming
behind Saga Odin and Tor are obviously
based on Odin and Thor for Norse
mythology in fact their names correlate
to their battle with the dark presence
as Odin like the God had his eye cut by
the dark presence but there's a funny
line in a manuscript where Odin is
pissed cuz he cut the wrong eye
eventually Tor ended up having a child
named Freya who is saga's Mom Saga is
the only one of the family not named
after a God but the word Saga is another
name for a story or tale and Saga is
here to change that story so her being
called Saga was completely intentional
and a nice touch nearby the trailer is
an ominous figure who is stalking her
this turns out to be Mulligan one of the
Deputy duo we saw in the intro and the
same ones who were dead in Allen's
campaign they seem to be allied with the
Cults meaning that they were watching us
investigate a murder that they committed
however a manuscript page explains that
they accidentally killed an innocent
girl this is something we'll learn from
ilmo later but the The Cult of the tree
are not the bad guys far from it
actually the cult that we saw kill
Nightingale are a sort of neighborhood
watch for the town they know of the dark
place the lake and the taken so they
protect the town from those that wash up
on shore that's why they hunted
Nightingale as that's where he came from
the ritual stuff is reminiscent of what
Allen did to the dark presence he took
the clicker and put it in Barbara's
chest to defeat her so the cult is doing
that with the victims who become taken
the reason it didn't work for
Nightingales cuz they were interrupted
those two teens that were trespassing
and happen to catch them interrupted the
ritual So in theory had they succeeded
nanga wouldn't have come back alive and
actually would have died thoron and
Mulligan are a part of that group but
were all hunting one day for taken and
Mist took one for an innocent girl named
Monica this creates a rather interesting
connection to Allen's side of the story
as the two cops killed an innocent girl
and then dumped her body in the well
hoping no one would find out but in
Allen's story two cops are trying to
rise through the ranks using this nearby
shoot to dumb bodies killed by The Cult
of the word into the well Allen's story
is like a perverted Twisted version of
what happened in the real world and due
to him having some kind of Clairvoyance
he is well aware of these events that
are happening this is also why the well
creates an overlap as the killing of
that girl is a part of the town's dark
past so Allen used that and create a
story within the dark place spawning the
overlap going inside has Saga fighting
the two at the same time which is quite
intense defeating them grants her the
clicker as well as a conversation with
Allen just like the others while Saga
returns to brief the group we see a
quick scene from Bri Falls where the
cult raid the lodge where Allen and
Casey are staying that's a little
strange given I just mentioned they only
hun taken but according to them anything
that comes out of that lake is evil
especially Allan Wake as he was the
cause of the events back in the first
game Casey attempts to fight them off
but Allan starts to send scratch before
blocking out I got to say these brief
moments of Casey really makes me hope
that he gets his own little DLC as
everything out of his mouth is just pure
gold due to his line
delivery
FBI we want the rider no one else needs
to get hurt [__] off Ellen manages to
wake up after the destruction has been
dealt and ends up running throughout the
woods to to find Casey Allen manages to
catch up but is then taken down by a
cult member only for Saga to save him
just in time only for the FBC to come
strolling in and take a hold the
operation the cult member's mask comes
off and is revealed to be ilmo the man
from earlier he and his brother yako are
the leaders of the cult the leader of
this specific task force though is Agent
Estes which is a nice call back to
control as Langston mentioned that she
was the lead agent ight Falls so it's
nice to put a face to the name just like
all the FBC though she is completely
desensitized to all this and is all
business that was always one of my fav
Parts about control how all the
employees could see someone squatted
across the wall but consider it a normal
Tuesday thanks to their profession it's
good to see them keep that same
personality with Estes but Saga is now
left with no leads thanks to the FBC
taking the operation and no partner as
Casey is missing fortunately the
Anderson Brothers gave her a call and
asked her to come back to the nursing
home this place is called the Valhalla
nursing home because of course it is and
is when she discovers her powers as an
Anderson as Odin is able to take control
of the profiling Booth which is
something that she's never experienced
before well on the call with the
brothers though Tor Was Heard being
attacked which is when we see him being
dragged into the lake by Cynthia Weaver
the lamp lady from the first game
watching over all the elderly is also
Rose the waitress from the diner the
dark presence still seems to have an
effect on her mind but she's definitely
doing much better than she was before
Rose will then explain that toor has
become obsessed with Cynthia recently
and has been flirting with her it feels
like she's casted a spell on him as he's
been obeying everything she says however
she is most definitely an ally of the
dark presence now so it's probably the
dark presence trying to finally kill the
brothers how this happened is actually
quite sad Cindy had always been fight in
the dark presence but after years and
years she started to become old and
frail she tried to continue placing
stashes and setting up lights but it
became too much for her one day she was
sitting in the bathroom clutching a lamp
before it went out followed by a voice
speaking to her from the darkness
Cynthia then tried to stand up but
slipped and fell into the tub where the
dark presence managed to finally take
her over this lines up perfectly with
how we find her in Allen's campaign to
get them though we're going to need to
open the overlap which is done by
playing a record in the Jukebox turning
that on is going to require us to get
the power on as Cynthia turned it off
which is when I discovered how much of
an epic gamer I am because I discovered
a speedrun skip that allows me to clip
through the ceiling as apparently the
containers have Collision so moving
forward while it op shoots you above it
incredible this is also around the time
I realized just how terrifying this game
can be I'm not sure why this place of
all places was the one to do it but I
think it was the flashing faces of
Cynthia coupled with the complete
silence of these areas while Allen wake
2 wasn't as scary as something like
alien isolation or Resident Evil 7 which
I consider to some of the scariest
survival horror games I've ever played
the dark forests are dense enough to
hide anything standing next to them and
more often than not the taken are hiding
in these exact places and most of the
locations feel equally abandoned yet
lived in like it's intentionally
abandoned so the residents can Ambush
those who enter I felt that mostly in
saga's campaign and it's a solid change
between the two as most of the enemies
in Allen's campaign are front and Setter
but figuring out who's going to attack
you or not is where the horror comes in
with Saga you're allowed to shoot
anything that moves but that's assuming
you can find them before they find you
defeating Cynthia relinquishes the dark
presence control over her and rescues
Tor we get another conversation but from
saga's side again which ends with her
being mad at alen for writing her
daughter into the story without a
consent to get some answers from Allen
Saga decides to go back to the sheriff
station which is where the FBC is hold
up down here is also Alex Casey who
managed to find his way back to town but
from an injury report and a profiling
case we learn that Casey is a lot more
injured than he implies as he seems to
have been expose to the darkness from
the dark place a small hint of Darkness
though is going to be the least of
everyone's worries as Allen is down here
in the cells but Allen was not Allan but
Mr
scratch sort of how this happened is
shown at the end of Allen's campaign
past the part we were stuck on but
basically Allan was infected by the dark
presence right before he was taken out
turning Allen into scratch in that
ending a Dark Void comes to consume
Allan it's best to think of that void as
scratch that's why when we eventually
defeat scratch Allen is still okay and
back to his normal self this creates a
very concerning Revelation that is about
to be revealed in just a moment but
that's something we'll have to discuss
in the next section as this is past the
point of no return so for now let's wrap
up our talk with
Saga as I mentioned in the prior section
I actually enjoyed saga's campaign more
which is surprising given the stories
about Alan Wake L not to say Allen
section was bad is I've already
discussed at length why it's just as
good but Saga was great for its own
reasons whereas Allen was great because
of the Mysteries sagas was great because
we got answers to the Mysteries not all
of it to be fair as most of alen's
campaign is left out of saga's story but
the question surrounding the cult and
their motives was explained in grave
detail
it does go against that quote of Stephen
Kings about leaving questions unanswered
but most of the stuff is not integral to
the overall plot the cult are important
but it's definitely something that
should be answered and not left in the
dark as we have more important things to
focus on like Mr scratch his role in all
this is also not only fascinating on its
own but it's further Amplified by the
Dual protagonist system Saga is under
the impression that Alan wrote return
and thus made her daughter a part of the
story and if you continue with her story
then you go on believing that but going
through Allen's story first means we
already know who wrote it and that Saga
is wrong I think that's why there's no
wrong way to play the game as the
content that needs to be answered will
be but how you experience it is up to
you you create your own personal
experience as for me I wasn't phased At
All by saga's comment about her daughter
because I knew it was going on but
someone who kept playing as Saga might
start to see Allan as the bad guy when
that's not true it's an incredible thing
to witness unfold and being able to
craft unique experience in a survival
horror game like this is downright
impressive as I've never seen it done
before both Saga and Allen are fantastic
characters each in their own ways and
giv the play the time to experience
their sides of the story removes the
problem spending too much time on one
character while neglecting the other as
it's up to the player to decide how they
want to proceed as much as I like Saga
though I do like Alan Wake more I also
don't recall the series being titled
Saga Anderson so we should probably get
back to the story and save Allan before
we have to change the
name the finale starts from saga's
perspective because Allan is uh
currently busy at the moment the plan is
to call up the Anderson Brothers and
perform a concert the music connected
with the dark place and the clicker
should be be able to get alen out of the
dark place so like Allen's campaign
we're going to have to fight a wave of
Tak him with our own Musical theme in
the background once finished Saga
activates the clicker which sends Allen
back to the real world but like we
talked about before it didn't send him
back to this time but to the past when
he arrives on the shore how is that
possible well the game gives us control
of alen so we can find out ourselves
Parliament Tower is now open and taking
it up to the top shows the same things
as before Alice's Art Exhibit and the
writer's room but this time what occurs
is a lot more important the last clip of
Alice's exhibit talks about her fight
with her mind Alice is still seeing
scratch and can't wake up from this
nightmare that she feels like she's in
but it's the final scene that really
sets the tone here Alice says that the
artist will now become the art before
some ominous text comes up that Sayes
that shortly after this recording Alice
took her own life Alice is dead she's
been dead this whole time we were trying
to get Alan back to her but she's been
gone for years the way the scene is
presented is perfect no music no audio
just the sound of static as we slowly
see Alice take her own life it's
horrifying and probably the scariest
scene in the game a perfect example of
less is more no jump Cuts bright flashes
or intense score just the raw emotions
of a person at the end of the Rope it's
terrifying but brilliantly presented
upon hearing this Allan goes into a rage
walks into the writer's room and shoot
scratch or did he alen has been both the
victim and now the killer in this exact
scene so how can that be well scratch
and Allen are one and the same it wasn't
scratch who tortured Alice day in and
day out it was Allan to put it simply
Allan is Allan but scratch is Allan with
the dark presence inside of him this
whole time Allan thought the dark
presence was hunting him such as when
scratch appeared during the lodge
incident but the dark presence was
actually inside of him the whole time as
it was just regaining its strength back
so it could finally take him over that's
why after fighting scratch who appears
after our concert alen is able to be
saved but thanks to Casey being affected
by the darkness scratch has found the
new host as for how Allen had no idea
well this is likely to impart to his
memories face fading the collaboration
he was going to make with Tomas Zay was
likely a long time ago but due to him
losing his memories he had forgotten
that he wrote it this however starts to
get a little murky when we consider
American Nightmare and even the ending
of the first game as they both exist
independently from one another so I'm
honestly not sure what to make of this
my only explanation is that the dark
presence was just assuming the form of
Allen back then but in here it was
actually controlling and manipulating
him as a silver lining though this is
the first time in years alen has had a
clear head now the dark presence is
taking someone else over so I can
imagine that probably feels quite
rejuvenating either way the plan now is
to go back to Bright Falls and enter
that portal that scratch created to
hopefully fix all this damage as not
only has Casey been taken over by
scratch but he also threw Saga into the
lake so now she's in the dark place the
portal then takes him to another bright
Falls but returns version of it similar
to the first game Al is going to have to
change the ending of the book for this
to work but he's still in the confines
of the story and in another meta moment
one of the last moments of return is
Allan returning to Bright Falls during
deerfest where celebrating the release
of the book Return the town's folk end
up attacking him so he attempts to get
away by going back to the nursing home
and opening the door with the spiral on
it while this happens we get to see
saga's first stay in the dark place
which goes about as bad as alen's first
time in the dark place the game
continues to use the environment to
convey this but instead of us fighting
the forces of dark or alen's dark
thoughts we're now going to battle
through saga's mind with her mind place
the dark place erased all ofer cases
from the board and none of the other
stuff works either like the upgrades of
the profiling I actually ran into this
really weird bug where I was stuck in
one of the menu so now I and Saga were
stuck in the dark place forever talk
about immersive many of the notes now
say very negative things like how she's
a bad mother or how she got Casey hurt
similarly to Alan she goes down a
complete spiral causing her to think
worse and worse thoughts about herself
but eventually she's able to regain
focus and be at peace where she ends up
is the same place Allan was back in his
campaign except the person who calls her
though isn't Thomas but Alice she tells
her to go to The Shoe Box by the statue
which if you remember contains the
photos of the clicker and the bullet
that we we put in there before we left
Allen's campaign Saga is going to use
this to create the ending for the story
to make it stick Allan needs to once
again follow the criteria of an
entertaining novel it needs to fit with
the horror genre of the book flow well
with the rest of the story but also help
him get the ending he wants but unlike
last time he's not alone Saga has become
a vital part of the story to the point
where the two could be considered
co-authors of return so the two are
going to make up the story together in a
horror story though there are only
victims in Monsters and the hero will
have to pay a heavy price this price is
death Saga appears in the writer's room
next to Alan right after scratch appears
still holding over control of Casey it
then leaves its body and takes over
Allen only for Saga to use the bullet
from the photo on him a bullet so bright
it apparently hurts to look at the
perfect Silver Bullet for the darkness
Saga then pulls the trigger and shoots
Allan killing the dark presence and him
in one shot it then ends with Saga
calling her daughter hoping that she
will pick up as that would mean that the
story has changed as she would no longer
be dead as the story claimed but we
don't get to see that as the credit
start
rolling this isn't the end of the story
though is after the credits we get a
final message from Alice she apologizes
to us as everything she made was meant
to deceive us Alice got in contact with
the FBC a while ago and was able to
remember much of her time in the dark
place before Allan changed the story in
the first game in here she was able to
notice that Alan was alive and not dead
as she originally thought those
hauntings of scratch weren't terrifying
her as they were further confirmations
that Alan was still out there she knew
that Alan was alive but stuck in the
dark place so she used her own form of
art for photography and try to get him
out those photos we used of the clicker
and the bullet came from her she was
willing to put them in the dark place
for us and the reason she was talking
with Saga is because she's in the dark
place now she came back to get Allen out
that's when the following scene showed
that Allan lived ending the game with
the line it's not a loop it's a spiral
Allen is not going through the same
events as he's slowly creating a spiral
and this one had him being revived after
being shot this is the first time he's
managed to live this encounter all game
so it's clear he's moved on to the next
stage stage of the Spiral long story
short Allen is alive Alice is also alive
and both of them are stuck in the dark
place which brings an end to Alan Wake
2 overall it's a great conclusion that
also sets up the next part of the story
if this game is anything like the first
then the DLCs will continue from here
and remedy has confirmed that Alam m 2
will get two paid DLCs called lak house
and night Springs lak house could deal
with the actual plot as Saga and Casey
are still presumably in the dark place
along with Allan and Alice who are most
definitely there and night Springs could
possibly be about control as Jesse and
Dr darling do show up very briefly
during our talk with Thomas and on
screen is the night Springs logo alen W
2 also seems to be getting some free
post-launch content like a new game plus
as well as a nightmare mode which seems
to be like the previous game's nightmare
mode which gives out specific
manuscripts only in that difficulty so
I'll be interested to see what the other
pieces of lur are that are in these
exclusive Pages outside of that that is
all the information we have but it's
clear that Alan way 2 and by extension
the remedy connected universe is just
beginning remedy truly outdid themselves
with Alan Wake too it's a culmination of
all their successes and failures from
their prior games mixed with their
unique sense of style that they've
managed to develop throughout these
games it's hard to overstate just how
impressive the Dual protagonist system
is and how they manage to make both the
gameplay and the story enjoyable by
allowing the player to craft Their Own
Story the gameplay between the two
characters is vared enough to feel
different bringing a sense of freshness
to the combat at any given time and the
choose your own adventurous style of
Storytelling let the audience dictate
the pace it's truly one of the finest
horror games this year and that's a hard
Club to get into given who's in
attendance this year Allan W to with
stands with the best of them and I hope
that remedy keeps this style of gameplay
in mind for the next entry if there is
one although given the previous game
remedy is probably going to change the
gameplay the DLC to test the waters to
see how far they could push the game
again who knows we might get another
action style American Nightmare game
where Allen uses ARs and full auto
shotguns again but that's going to be it
for me today Len wake 1 has always been
one of my favorite games of all time and
I'm glad that I was able to play and
talk about the second one with you all
today once again if you need a quick
refresher for the first game you can
watch my previous video as well as my
other story analysis videos if that
interests you like the video if you
enjoy and subscribe if you're new thank
you to my returning viewers and coming
back to another video and take care
everyone
goodbye